hi everyone welcome to today's broadcast
improving the design and reporting of
animal research to optimize the
participating of animal studies I'm
Natalie Percy dinner for men see-through
yards and I'll be your moderator for
today's event so we have a few important
announcements before we begin so this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green create a button at the lower left
of the presentation window and we'll try
to answer as many questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
and if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your program for the
green Q&A button lower left I now like
to introduce to the speakers dr. Katie
Lisa and Katie is science manager at the
National Center for three hours which he
joined in 2013 she works with the
research management and policy group and
he is invited to your project in the
office including there are guidelines
which is going to talk about today
priority B is Katie up to the PhD in um
analogy and worked as a postdoctoral
researchers at Queen Mary University of
London on multiple sclerosis so I'll now
turn it over to Katie for our
presentation okay thank you very much
Leslie and thank you for joining us
today I'd also like to thank the
organizers for giving us the opportunity
to speak to you today a bit more about
what we do at the NC 3 hours and the
resources we have available so today I'm
going to concentrate on the design and
reporting of animal research and how
they improve in these you can optimize
reproducibility of animal studies
specifically I'll be focusing on the
arrive guidelines
why these were developed how they were
developed and how they used in the
scientific community and then I'll also
spend a few moments talking about the
EDA which the new experimental design
assistant that we've recently launched
so firstly if you're not familiar with
the NC 3 yards of the national center
for the replacement requirements and
reduction of animals we are a UK
organization based in London but we work
nationally and internationally and we
done a discovery and application of new
technologies and approaches to replace
reduce and refine the use of animals in
scientific purposes so we use a 303
hours as a framework to support science
innovation and animal welfare in the UK
and abroad we work with the scientific
community including research vendors
academia industry and regulators if
you'd like to find out more about what
the NC 3 hours do it does and what some
of the projects we firmed please do
visit our website and I also suggest
that you may like to sign up to our
monthly newsletter this news data gives
you the latest updates and three hours
research any events or publications
coming from the organization so what is
it that NC 3 yards does so what are the
main things we do is we burned three
hours research we do this in a
traditional manner with project grants
and pilot grants and strategic awards
where we provide provide funding to
create new models tools and approaches
for the 3 R's we also have an innovative
research funding scheme called crackit
which is an open innovation call which
aim to commercialize 3 R's approaches we
also nurture tomorrow's leaders so the
early career researchers by providing
three hours fellowships and studentships
aside from the 3 R's funding we also
have a range of scientists that work for
the organisation that lead their own
scientific projects within the NC 3
hours this is normally done through the
means of an expert working group well
through these expert working group the
NC 3 hours can act as an honest broker
to gather evidence and using this
evidence we can influence decision
making and change policy practice and
regulatory change we also promote the 3
R's and raise awareness of them so this
through information resources such as
our website we also host a variety of
events throughout the year and we
produce guidance and publications so
today I'm going to talk mostly about the
arrive guidelines and how we can use
these to promote practice change in the
reporting of animal research as I said
the NC 3 R's has a range of resources
and please do check these out on
website we have an extensive library
which covers everything from practical
information publications videos and
training material these are to help
researchers veterinarians animal care
staff to implement the 3 R's so that the
NC 3 R's we have a program of were
dedicated to experimental design which
is led by my colleague dr. Nathalie
Percy to sir appropriate experimental
design analysis reporting a key means of
minimizing the use of animals in
research and we have two key tools which
you can use to help you with this we
have the arrive guidelines in which I
call the animal reporting research in
vivo experiments and EDA experimental
design assistant so as you know this
dream this talk is up in the stream for
reproducibility in animal research and
I'm sure this issue will come up quite a
few times in their talks this afternoon
you may have seen some of these
headline-grabbing articles about the low
reproducibility in animal research
they've hit the scientific literature
and also the mainstream media low
reproduce speak in animal research has a
variety of consequences firstly it
hinders a scientific process therefore
delaying the the translation of jokes
too into the clinic and when patients
receive these drugs
it also wastes animal lives if these lat
if these studies can't be repeated and
then they can't be translated also it
has an economical impact a recent survey
we wrote a it cost about twenty eight
billion dollars per year for preclinical
research there's a variety of examples
coming out of the scientific nature of
irreproducible research over the past
few years in this review here just shows
you some examples of these and the range
of reproducible research varies quite
significantly from anything from 89% to
51% I've highlighted here to keep
applications that brought this to the
light so for example Begley in comic
colleagues from Amgen did some
invalidation studies and tried to
replicate
53 studies in the lab but they were only
able to replicate seven studies not only
did they just use the reporting in the
manuscript they were also in touch with
the researchers themselves and they were
still enabled to
reproduce the majority of these studies
also this article by Prince and
colleagues from Bayer did a similar
approach where they looked at in-house
validation of projects and also found
out that way over two thirds of these
could not be repeated in their in their
in those labs so this isn't a on its own
the MC three RS have done a series of
some work around this as well so in 2009
we carried out a survey which where the
time was a bigger survey of its kind we
looked at over two hundred and seventy
papers of UK and us publicly funded
animal research in rats mice and
non-human primates and we looked at the
quality of the design the analysis and
reporting in these studies and what we
found is with experimental design only
12% of publications reported
randomization and 14 percent reported
blinding that means that the majority of
these papers have made no attempt to
reduce subjective bias also simple size
justification was missing in all of
these publications looking at
statistical analysis only 70% of these
publications fully describe the
statistical methods and presented these
with a minute measure of variability
such as standard deviation or standard
error this may seem quite high but that
means that 30% of these studies didn't
show how they analyze their results and
finally looking at the reporting of
cities so a loss of the characteristics
of the animals that were used in the
cities were missing and only 15 59
percent of cases were all three
important pieces of information provided
which were the hypothesis number of
animals and characteristic of animals so
from this survey we found that there was
key areas of fur improvement so the
first area for improvement was looking
at the reporting of animal research and
this is where we set up an expert
working group this working group
consisted of scientists statisticians
and journal editors and together they
developed the arrive guidelines which
were a checklist of 20 items containing
key information necessary to describe a
study comprehensively and transparently
we worked with research Monroes and
scientists and very tested these and
these were published in PLoS Biology in
2000
ten you can use the arrived guidelines
to ensure that reproduce live animal
research and avoid unnecessary animal
use so what do the arrived guidelines
look like this is an overview of what
the items are and as you can see they're
listed in chronological order of how you
would go through a manuscript so
everything from a title to that abstract
introduction so the background of why
you chose the species and your
objectives that you set out for your
study due to methods such as study
design so did you take steps to reduce
bias such as blinding and randomization
how did you carry out the study and and
some characteristics of the animals
through to results such as how the
statistics were analyzed and any adverse
events that you may have seen in your
study all the way through to discussions
so looking at how the generalizability
of your study and if it can be
translated to other species or into
humans however you can also think of the
20 items broken down into three main
groups as I said all twenty items are
important for reporting and studies and
although really important for
reproducibility we can break this down a
bit further into what they are important
for and why you should include them in
yesterday so the first theme is internal
validity so these are items that
required to assess how robust the
results are so as I said things like how
animals were allocated to groups and
statistical methods and how the number
of animals that was arrived at
and then for reproducibility these are
items described information necessary
for you to go away and to repeat that
study so how was the study done what
what was the methods use where the
animals kept and looking at their cages
and also any adverse effects the third
group of items is for context and
scientific relevance so these are items
provide context and scientific relevance
of the study to allow study to be
through to go through the peer review
service so these are really important
things to know such as the background to
your study and your objectives all the
way through to the translation of your
study as I said all twenty items are
required to maximize information
published and to minimize unnecessarily
animal use
so I'm just going to go a bit further
into some of those items and explain a
bit more about why they're important to
report in your manuscripts and also
provide you evidence where it is
possible to support this so first of all
looking at study design we looked at
blinding so blinding is a research
strategy that you can do to keep people
who conduct assess and analyze the data
and aware of the treatment allocation so
this study here was a systematic review
of animal models of multiple sclerosis
and they categorized them into two
groups
they had non blinded studies and blinded
studies and as you can see here from the
non blinded studies the effect size was
about 41%
however in blinded studies the effect
size was reduced reduced to only 30%
therefore the studies are not blinded
overestimate treatment efficacy you also
see a similar picture when we look at
allocation of animals so you can use
randomization to minimize selection bias
and reduce systematic differences when
allocating allocating animals to
different treatment groups in the same
study the authors split the split the
studies into non randomized studies and
these had an effect size of 42% however
in randomized studies the effect size
was only 21% only half of the effect
size of non randomized studies so there
again studies not randomized
overestimated treatment efficacy moving
on to reproducibility so these these
items that are needed for you to go away
and so you can replicate the study again
so one one of the things that really
needs to be reported is the experimental
procedures this includes how you carried
out your procedure when such as time of
day where where does your current
procedure such as in the laboratory or
in a water made and why you chose that
procedure and this just shows you
example here of how the site of
administration of sampling can happen
ahead effects on your experimental
results so enlisted Lee they looked at
Acutes information in a mouse model and
they took blood samples from the facial
vein and from the cardia from the heart
and what they found was that the
location the blood sampling can have an
effect on the cytokine concentrations
and his consequence
consequentially the inflammatory insults
so you can hear that see here that the
il-6 concentration the facial drei
facial vein is significantly lower than
from the heart moving on to the animals
that we use in the experiment it's
important to report what the
characteristics were of the animals that
were used so things such as species
drain sex source of animals and any
genetic modifications in the genotype
you may have come across this one quite
a bit in the literature as the NIH have
promoted a new policy to balance sex in
cell and animal studies in some animal
studies researchers chose choose to use
only male mice due to the East recycle
having effects on some experimental
studies however the NIH have introduced
new policies and funding calls to
balance out the sexes in animal
experiments for example in rodent models
of osteoarthritis sex human hormones can
play a role in the progression of
osteoarthritis so males develop more
severe osteoarthritis than females and I
think following my talk there ISM when I
was talking about how sex can be a huge
variability in your experiments I'm
finally moving on to housing and
husbandry so it's important to note the
details of the housing and has written
today about how the animals were kept
such as the type of cage or housing
bedding material the lights dark cycle
and temperature and environmental
enrichment so I provided an example here
about the housing so this was a group of
mice that would wear her de surgery to
develop neuropathic pain and what they
found was at the bedding texture of
these mice affected how they reacted in
a pin prick test so mice that were kept
on a coarse bedding showed a lower
response rate to the pin prick test
compared to mice that were kept up on a
fine bedding so you can see here how
housing had have a huge effect on the
outcome of your study and secondly it
provided some evidence about the
husbandry so the temperature that
animals are kept at you may have seen
this article in the literature last year
where there was a cancer study where
animals were kept at low temp
and low temperatures induce suppression
of the anti-tumor immune response and
therefore motive to tumor growth and
metastasis many animals kept at room
temperature which is actually too cold
for the natural environment miss induces
a stress response can affect many of the
studies and act as another variability
so it's therefore very important that
this detail is included in your
manuscripts so we know how the study was
conducted and it can be reproduced I'm
finally moving on to the last section
the contexts and scientific relevant so
these are items relating to the content
of the study including things like the
abstracts the object of the study and
the ethics behind the animal experiments
and also things like the funding this
minimum amount of information is needed
so that a study can go through the peer
review process
you can't peer review a paper if you
don't know what happened to the animals
and therefore it's important to report
all the twenty items have arrived so the
peer reviewer can understand and analyze
the quality of the experiment it's also
important for systematic reviews and
meta-analysis of animal data this data
is required to identify the relevant
studies and also to assess preclinical
evidence so for example funding sources
can have an impact on the outcome of a
study this recent systematic review
looked at the effect of statins and they
found that the effect of statins is
greater in studies with non industry
sponsorship compared to industry
sponsored studies
who uses the arrived guidelines the
arrive guidelines are used all over the
world if we send out copies of the
arrive guidelines upon request if you on
our website we've sent over 10,000
copies in the past two years to Reber 38
different countries and one of our first
goals in promoting arrive is to promote
them as widely as possible we also have
translations we have translations
available in Brazilian Portuguese
Spanish and Mandarin and Italian I'm a
future translations in Korean and
Japanese so the arrived guidelines are
endorsed by all scientific and
organizations and we see it as that
improve reporting is a collaborative
endeavor and that all organizations
involved in science should play a role
so this comes from the very beginning
from the funders who support the
research through to universities where
the research is carried out the learned
societies that support the researchers
and then finally the journals the
gatekeepers of research before the
research is published and by working
together with all these organizations
and using the arrived guidelines we aim
to improve the reporting of animal
research so firstly looking at offenders
as I said the core of the funding at the
very beginning so it's important place
to promote the arrived guidelines the
main UK funders MRC Wellcome Trust BBSRC
signed up to the arrived guidelines when
they're initially published as part of
the responsibility document this
responsibility document is supported by
all UK major research funders and it
sets our expectations of the fenders for
using animals in research in the UK as
time has progressed the UK foreigners
have backed arrived and most recently
they have changed their part their
policies to include arrived at the very
beginning in the grant review process
and firmly embedded and arrived at the
beginning of the process also NIH have
led for eight many initiatives to
improve the reproducibility and these
also include reference to the arrived
guidelines and encourage for refunded
researchers to use the route guidelines
where
we work with universities to encourage
them to use the arrive guidelines and in
2013 we launched a call to UK
universities to ask them to encourage
research staff and students to use the
guidelines we did this by setting out a
criteria to help universities implement
me and he suggested criteria included an
institutional policy on animal research
a public statement on their website
showing their endorsement for arrived
guideline an inclusion of the arrived
guidelines in their licensee training
courses and research training courses
and the making the arrived guidelines
available within their internal
communications follow meal is called the
majority of UK research funding research
universities now endorsed the arrived
guidelines and some international
universities are also starting to
endorse arrive I highlighted this recent
article institutions must do their part
for reproducibility which just
underlines of what Institute's can do
and how they can change the reward
system to reward quality science and
moving on to societies so we work with
learning societies who can endorse the
arrived guidelines and can encourage
members to adopt the guidelines to
improve the quality of reporting in
their area of research so we ask society
to promote awareness and use of the
guidelines through their website through
newsletters and any events and we have
over 25 societies that endure see arrive
guidelines currently in January 2015
face F which is the umbrella
organization for about 30 US bioscience
societies releases publication on how
they can enhance research
reproducibility as part of this is the
recommendation to improve reproduce
reproducibility by including promoting
awareness and use of the arrived
guidelines
and finally we work with journals to
endorse early write guidelines so we now
have over 600 journals that endorse the
right guidelines they do this by
incorporating them into their
instructions for authors or editorial
policies and encourage their authors
peer reviewers and editors to use the
arrived guidelines this week in nature
we were featured in the nature at Trent
watch where you can see the surge in
support for the study guidelines so this
shows the growing support over years
from 2010 to 2015 and you can see that
2015 was our biggest year yet with over
150 journals endorsing the arrived
guidelines if you'd like to see the full
list of journals these can be found on
our website
but I've provided a few examples of some
of the journals that endorse arrive
however we're seeing a new phase in
journal endorsement we're moving beyond
endorsement and into implementation and
many jelous have started to introduce
policies to improved reporting of animal
research so for example nature and plus
a few years ago introduced these
editorials where they said they would
change the policy to improve reporting
mess and save adopters do this include
author checklists removal of space
restrictions for methods sections to
allow authors to report all the
information and also the availability of
raw data the arrive guidelines are also
available on our website as an arrive
checklist and this can be quite useful
when you're submitting a manuscript you
can submit the manuscript with a
checklist and this helps to show the
peer reviewers and the editors where the
information is contained within your
manuscript we have many resources
available on our website to help support
the use of the guidelines as I said
there is the checklist which is
available to download as a PDF or a word
document we have translations in a
variety of languages we also have
examples of how in the literature each
item of arrive has been reported and we
also have a presentation and speaker
notes which can be used to disseminate
the Araya guidelines within your
Institute and we send out dead cards and
upon request through our website
so how can you use the arrived
guidelines they can be helpful when you
come to design your experiment and they
can be useful to consult prior to the
start of the study so you know what
information to include in your
manuscript as I said they're useful for
writing for writing manuscripts and also
for PhD theses and dissertations and
they can be very useful if you're
reviewing men's manuscripts they apply
to any area of bioscience research where
animals used and can be used for
comparative studies so using the arrived
guidelines you can help ensure that your
research is transparent accurate
comprehensive concise logically ordered
and well-written so now we've dealt with
the reporting of animal research I'd
like to touch upon the experimental
design assistant which is the new tool
that we have developed at the NRC three
hours to improve the design of animal
experiment so this is a web-based tool
which is composed of two components
there's a web-based app and then a
supporting website and this is aimed at
in vivo researchers it was developed in
collaboration between in vivo
researchers statisticians academia
industry and software designers
specialized in artificial intentions and
it has been row tested by many
researchers and statisticians so the EDA
offers a variety of benefits the first
benefit is that it gives you the ability
to build stepwise visual representation
of the experiment the EDA diagram so
what the EDA does is that you can use
these building blocks like Lego blocks
that we call nose and well put these
together so you can you can see the
experimental layout and within each of
these nodes you can add additional
properties and further information and
by visualizing your experiment as a
diagram this can be more explicit than
looking at a text description you can
use complex you can easily understand
complex designs the EDA also offers
feedback and advice in your experimental
plans so behind the ad a there is a set
of rules that are triggered in certain
scenarios for experimental design and
it'll provide you with further feedback
and advice and how to improve your
experimental design there is dedicated
support from randomization blinding in
sample
sighs calculations so here you can see
an example of how you can use the EDA to
develop your sample size calculation and
then once this is being calculated you
can put this into the system and a
randomization report can be generated
and sent to a colleague or blinding it
also offers practical information to
improve knowledge of experimental design
so as I said the the web the web app is
supported by a website which contains a
wealth of information on an experimental
design which is quite useful as a
standalone in as well as in addition to
the EDA and finally an EDA improves
transparency the experimental plan helps
communications they want to you have
developed your design you can share this
with collaborators and supervisors to
ensure transparency of your experimental
plan I recommend that you go online you
can get you give the idea ago.if
if you'd like further information we do
have a range of video tutorials that are
available on our website which you can
help you get started with the EDA and
finally to conclude I've taught today
about two key resources at the NCI of
develop to improve the design and
reporting of research using animals so I
spoke about the arrived guidelines and
how that using all twenty items of these
guidelines can be used to help improve
and the reporting then finally I've
touched upon the new experimental design
assistance which can be used to develop
for new your experimental design and
improve design and finally if you'd like
any further information please do visit
our website waiting download they
arrived guidelines and request further
copies or please do get in touch with me
and I'll be more than happy to answer
your questions and also keep in touch
and sign up to our monthly newsletter
which provides the latest updates from
the NC three hours
and thank you for listening
right thank you for that great
presentation and so before we get
started on the question and answer
session and actually might not audience
how to submit questions so you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be fun by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window and we'll try
to answer as many questions that we can
so our first question is so I noticed
that most universities have endorsed
derive guidelines I in the UK if a
university in the US wants to sign up I
would they go about it okay so if a u.s.
university would like to sign up it's
very much a similar criteria we could
help you embed the arrived guidelines
within your research training programs
we could share information about how the
UK universities have approached the use
of the arrived guidelines obviously
there is a slight difference in how
universities run in different countries
but we could depending on how your
Institute runs helped you to embed these
in your programs and I'd be more than
willing if you wanted to more
information just to get in touch 600
journals have signed up to the right
guidelines but how do you know that
reporting is actually improving okay so
it might take a while to find the
evidence that improve reporting and as a
result of the arrived guidelines we are
working closely with journals on this
subject so we are Co funding a project
to look at the effect of using the
arrived checklist and to see if this
improves the reporting of animal
research but I think it will take a time
for the evidence to emerge if the
arrived guidelines are having effect on
improving reporting okay don't think
there's any more question for the minute
maybe you can wait another 10 seconds
and see if anything else comes in
okay well there's no more questions I
like to once again thank Katie for a
presentation and do you have any final
comments I just like to thank you for
joining us today now if you have a good
evening or morning wherever you are
alright so today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing until
August and you'll receive an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay and we
invite you to forward the announcement
to your colleagues who might have missed
to this live event see you next time bye